what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
man if God was right in Green Lantern
right now is what it looks like right
now if God was what man let's have some
church right now if God was right in
green lantern right now is what it would
look like right now
this is one of the best stories that I
have ever read God his stories amazing
the stories absolutely insane ah it is
so cool because it takes like we think
about superheroes right and like it
turns it on its head it takes everything
that we think about superheroes and just
like flips it over like the crazy thing
about superheroes and it happens to a
degree but the crazy thing about
superheroes is that like historically
speaking there's like some enemy that
shows up and they're like oh my god this
enemy who's really powerful like there's
no way we can beat him but somehow like
they come together against impossible
odds and they win they save the day huh
no that's not what happens that's not
what happens in here the whole first
book of Sinestro Corps war is just like
1 3 4 your lives
it's the coolest thing ever it's just
like find a place to hide just go
somewhere anywhere that's not here like
it's one of the coolest things ever
because remember in the previous video
we talked about how like the Sinestro
Corps was like always in the background
the Sinestro Corps was always like
mustering up its forces and the
background there were just times when
would you show up in different stories
you just have like a page somewhere and
it would just say you have the ability
to instill great fear welcome to this
special court and it would be it it
would just go away
it was just vanished and the idea was
that it was building towards something
big man is it a sight to behold
it is amazing goddess of it the whole
thing is that when the Sinestro Corps
was officially formed they like raided
oh I mean it was just like just ripping
apart the Green Lantern's and that's
what's so cool about this because like
superboy-prime escapes and like cyborg
Superman is gone the anti-monitor is
allied with the Sinestro report imagine
all the worst things that could happen
with the Green Lantern's that's what
geoff johns writes from the story in the
first part of the story because
initially it's all just recuperation
right I mean like you know on OA it's
the idea that they were just totally
wrecked by the Sinestro report with no
expectation that it was coming and
that's the great thing about this it's
no one knew what was coming no one had
any idea was there they were just you
know meeting together and then suddenly
it was bad everybody just shows up these
these members of Sinestro Corps just
show up and just start crushing
everybody
that's so at this point it's just like
okay fallback
see if we can't get our forces together
let's see if we can't figure out what's
going on but in the midst of all this
like it's something like 55 56 the
number just keeps going up the numbers
of lanterns flame just keeps going up
and that's the whole thing because what
they say here is that like uh Noah the
the assault of the Sinestro Corps is
basically stopped because they were
there to capture Kyle Lena I mean it
wasn't expected but when they found him
there and found him as the host for the
will power entity in the emotional
spectrum they smashed him up took them
to took them to court you know with the
antimatter universe and then they backed
off but across the universe Green
Lantern's are dying everywhere and
that's what makes this so cool because
it's like this huge encompassing opera
with everything that we see going on in
the story right now keep in the back of
your minds Green Lantern's across the
universe just dying it's one of the
coolest things in the world like you to
see these numbers just just cranking out
you know occasionally it's just you know
67 Lantern's dead or so on and so forth
you see rings fly by Green Lantern is
sector such and such deceased searching
out viable replacement whatever the case
may be now the other half of this is the
book of OA and that's what makes this so
cool because remember the book of OA
serves as both a general guide as well
as a chronicle of everything that's gone
on and the whole history of the
guardians of the universe the Green
Lantern's all the forces they face
Sinestro falling from grace all that
kind of good stuff but the idea is that
there's also the prophecy of blackest
night now the cool thing about this is
that if you just suddenly jump into
Sinestro Corps war you could still kind
of you know get a general idea of what's
going on but it's a lot more fulfilling
and there's a lot more meat and potatoes
to it if you don't do and start reading
the stories beforehand which is why I
always tell people if you're going to
read Green Lantern read Green Lantern
Corps and read Green Lantern go all the
way back you know really to rebirth and
just work your way forward with regards
to the whole Hal Jordan and Green
Lantern mythos but what this does is it
tells us that while all these Green
Lantern's are sitting around and dying
the guardians of the universe are more
or less playing politics now we kind of
expect that to be the case right like we
expect with the guardians of the
universe that they're going to be
playing politics are going to be doing
their thing or they're going to be
engaging in bureaucracy and talking
about what they should do and all that
kind of good stuff and how things should
happen and function and so on and so
forth but remember the original idea of
the guardians of the universe is that
they would catch their emotions aside
they would basically say we are devoid
of all emotion whatsoever now of course
again we know right now just because of
DC rebirth the last will and testament
of the of the first Lantern we know all
that deals with the facts but they were
basically taught how to
how to harness the emotional spectrum by
volthoom and began to realize that
tapping into their emotions was too
extreme and they basically cast in the
cloud and made themselves just totally
devoid of any real feeling whatsoever
believing that strictly rational thought
would be the only way to go but the idea
was that with a bandsaw or being the
Green Lantern predecessor - Hal Jordan
which is to say the guy that basically
gave Hal Jordan his ring evidence or
have been told by Atrocitus the head of
the Red Lantern Corps of the prophecy of
blackest night now the funny thing about
this is a question that you know that
ganthet and sayd have because remember
the Guardians never usually take names
so it's basically Jeff John's way of
saying these two are going to play a
very important role as we go on
throughout the Green Lantern mythos but
the argument that ganthet and sayd had
is look if the rest of the guardians
consider the prophecy of the blackest
night to be nonsense if they consider it
to be just this sort of a scare tactic
that was used by Atrocitus for the
purpose of weakening the will power of a
band soar through fear and then using
that to defeat him then why in the world
did the guardians of the universe record
it in the first place it would be like
if I came to you and I said oh man like
the planets going to blow up tomorrow
and you're like whatever that's nonsense
I don't believe a single word of that
and then you started making arrangements
in case the planet did blow up if you
didn't really think it was real then why
are you making these arrangements in the
first place and so what this does is it
basically reveals to us the idea that
while a lot of these different guardians
them are more or less hers of their
emotions on a very fundamental level on
a very personal level they're terrified
they're terrified of the idea that the
prophecy of lacus 9 is real that it's
true because if it is it means those
guardians are all going to die
it means the Green Lantern's we're all
going to die it means there's going to
be nothing but death and destruction
across the universe for ever and ever
and ever and ever and so again it's the
idea that they're basically faced with
their own mortality and that's one of
the reasons why I love this little piece
of writing so much with Jeff John
because it begs the question if you were
a race and it basically been around for
billions of years and then we're
suddenly forced to face the idea that
you're not as omnipotent as you think
you were and that you can die just like
anybody else would you really be
prepared would you be absolutely
terrified are you so used to living but
you can imagine not being alive and so
again which help from ganthet and sayd
how Jordan has basically informed and of
course Kyle Rayner is being held on for
the home base of the the Sinestro Corps
at least at this particular point in
time now keep in mind here Hal Jordan is
kind of like this Green Lantern that
fell from grace he's still considered to
be like the best of them in terms of
what he can do how it uses ring the
I could he's like you know first one in
last one out that whole element makes
them one of the greatest Green Lantern's
among them but there's a lot who don't
trust him because remember factoring and
multiply light following the destruction
of Co city by a by Mongol and cyborg he
felt such a rush of fear that he was
basically taken over by parallax the
embodiment of fear within the emotional
spectrum he went forward as a villain he
basically laid waste to the entirety of
the Green Lantern Corps killed the
guardians of the universe for a lot of
Green Lantern's out there they look at
him and what if it happened again and
that's one of the crazy scenarios that
level of trust just isn't there anymore
and it never really will be I mean the
lost lanterns the ones who were believed
to have been killed by him only to have
been taken by cyborg superman and used
for experiments eventually being rescued
by you know Hal Jordan and Guy Gardner
and so on and so forth they specifically
will never trust house warden again but
they constantly keep reminding of
everybody at the time that Hal Jordan
became a bad guy the time that Hal
Jordan was evil you know and so what
goes on here in the middle of all this
is that when you know Guy Gardner and
Jon Stewart and Hal Jordan go to charge
their rings in order to break the
interdimensional barrier and travel to
the antimatter universe and access court
we suddenly end up finding out that the
Central Power batteries basically been
booby-trapped and that's the coolest
thing because for years that before Jeff
Johnson took over the idea was that
Green Lantern's were just weak to the
color yellow but nobody ever knew why it
was just something that they you know
they were just weak to it it wasn't
until Jeff Jones came along and said the
guardians of the universe discovered
parallax to represent the very
embodiment of fear they can find him
inside the central power battery which
in turn is the reason why Green Lantern
reins were weak to fear in the first
place weak to the color yellow in the
first place parallax was eventually
freed the yellow impurity went away what
it did is it created this kind of
scenario where as like parallax always
had a backdoor into the central power
battery not only that you also have to
keep in mind Kyle Rayner was the host
for ion he was the host for willpower
he's part and parcel to the Green
Lantern's himself and so well I wouldn't
go as far as to say there's a central
power batteries like an arm or a leg for
Kyle Rayner it's not that much
intertwined in who he is he's still very
much a part of the fact that it
basically came back and so he's almost
able to sort of enter and leave as he
wants to but creating a sort of booby
trap is perfect because what it means is
that any green lantern that goes to
charge their rings will get a direct
shot of fear into their bodies because
remember the central power battery is
this massive source of energy this mass
source of willpower so it would be like
you sticking your finger in electrical
socket except instead of electricity you
feel a rush of fear and that's exactly
what happened with Hal Jordan where he's
normally able to overcome great fear
where he's normally one of the best of
the Green Lanterns he immediately
experiences this massive rush where he's
basically forced to relive the death of
his own father and what this does is it
allows kyle rayner to appear as parallax
and basically begin the process of
taunting Hal Jordan while risking him
away to the to the antimatter universe
of course now something else to point
out here is that we get a couple
instances here and there of Green
Lantern's who are either trying to make
their escape who don't really know
what's going on who aren't aware of the
fact that the Sinestro Corps is
attacking and once they do show up
they're just totally obliterated and
that's the crazy thing about this
because remember the universe is a big
place and it takes time when you have
the Sinestro Corps launching a surprise
attack then it takes time to basically
marshal forces together to get
information out there to let people know
what's going on so by the time some of
these Green Lantern's realize what it is
that's happening there suddenly ambushed
by like 50 members of the Sinestro Corps
and they have no hope of escape now
that's something else that I want you to
take note of here is because we end up
having Sinestro travelling back to his
home planet of kuru ger and the reason
why this is so important is because of
the fact that he basically visits
cirrhotic not to the girl who took up
his own Lantern his own Green Lantern
ring and became the Green Lantern of
Karuna now with her character being
elevated to this position it brought in
one of two possible scenarios the first
was that she never wanted to be a Green
Lantern in the first place just because
of the fact that she remembers when
Sinestro ruled over career and how
dictatorial he was in his policies but
the other half of this isn't terrified
her because she believed that people on
Krueger would view her the same way that
people would look around and say oh we
have a savior up there in the form of a
Green Lantern who's not Sinestro like
she'll lead us to the promised land
she'll give us a better society
she'll solve all of our problems for us
and that's what she was terrified of
because one of the things that's kind of
hit home when it comes to the Green
Lantern's is that the people that are
best suited to be Green Lantern's are
the people who know how to confront
their own problems and know how to deal
with their own problems hence the
necessity of willpower the willpower to
overcome such overwhelming odds and cope
with them as best you can but for
cirrhotic her fear is basically becoming
Sinestro not really at this point it's
just a matter of the nature of the Green
Lantern
raise and the fact that she's just not
as capable of a fighter as Sinestro is
now when I talk about the nature of the
Green Lantern rings there's an instance
when she tries to kill Sinestro the
problem with this is the rain stop sir
because one of the big weaknesses of the
Green Lantern rings is that initially
they were designed as a peacekeeping
force as opposed to a war force and so
the issue with this is that where she
tries to take out Sinestro the ring
immediately realizes her intention is
based on hostility her intention is
based on a desire to kill and it keeps
her from doing that and that's the
reason why so many of these Green
Lantern's are dying because they're
playing defense when they should be
playing offense because they don't have
a choice their rings will not allow them
to kill their rings will only allow them
to defend and so that's why this whole
first part of the story is just running
and hiding defending as best they can
keeping the Sinestro Corps at bay
because the Sinestro Corps does not have
that limitation those rings allow its
rulers to just kill whoever it is that
they come across especially if they're
if they're Green Lantern's because
remember the Sinestro Corps feeds on
fear it's powered by fear what better
way to to really know continue powering
a Sinestro report then - just incite
fear everywhere you go by killing Green
Lantern's in front of people by killing
them all over the place and so some of
these lost lanterns try to face off
against parallax as best they can but at
the end of the day they're not really
able to pull it off on their own and so
what ends up happening is the group
actually takes up residence underground
they really just kind of scatter to a
couple different couple different areas
but Hal Jordan a term or two they
actually end up taking up residence or
at least are coming across a woman by
the name of Lysa Drac now if you're
reading Hal Jordan and the Green
Lantern's are from from DC rebirth she's
very familiar - you saw her in the first
arc sinestro's lost oh she's a character
the dates all the way back to Geoff
Johns run and she was originally
introduced as just like this chronicler
of the Sinestro Corps she basically kept
the book of Sinestro the book of the
yellow lantern of the Sinestro Corps it
was just like the Book of Allah accepted
it chronicled everything from the
Sinestro Corps side so again what this
does is basically just give us this
massive conflict again outside of how
toward himself this massive conflict
from all these different lanterns all
across the universe all trying to stem
the flow as best they can but at the end
of the day not being able to hold off
all these members of the Sinestro Corps
now of course with regards to how Jordan
and his guys remember this is not van
engaging in conflict to kill this is
them
to rescue people where they can trying
to grab those who have been captured
trying to save those green lanterns so
we're out there in no-man's land don't
know what's going on or else ambushed by
a ton of a by a ton of yellow lanterns
recon and contained that's all this is
that's why there's action but there's
really more of like dialogue because
it's like what in the world is going on
everybody trying to get a grasp on the
situation now with regards to the
guardians of the universe again what
they start doing is talking about the
idea of rewriting the book of OA now the
reason why this is so significant is
because the book of OA is designed to be
this sort of guarantee promise among the
Green Lantern's right like it's this
idea that like no matter what any Green
Lantern does no matter what takes place
their accomplishments their failures
those who fall from grace those who
achieve great things their recordings
will go in the book of OA it literally
exists just chronicles everything that
goes on with the Green Lantern Corps and
so while some of these members of the
guardians of the universe talk about
rewriting the book of OA the concern of
ganthet and sayd is they're going to
write out the prophecy of blackest night
and so what that basically means is
these guardians would be tantamount to
sticking their head in the sand like
ostriches while all hell just unfolds
around them believing that if they just
ignore it then nothing will happen to
them but that storms coming either they
can face it and people here or they can
hide from it and be eradicated and so
the idea is that from ganthet and sayd
perspective it's we got to face this
like we got to be prepped a realize this
blackest night is coming and when it
does hell is coming with it we have to
be prepared for this and the other
Guardians are just like no no if we
ignore it it'll go away and so the idea
is that if they rewrite the Book of
Allah they'll basically remove the
prophecy of blackest night pretend like
it's not there despite knowing the fact
that it will be coming the entire time
it's going to be there the whole way now
of course again back with house running
his guys all they really do here is just
like free Guy Gardner and Jon Stewart
but Geoff Johns actually begins the
process of going through and introducing
the notion of a singular Lantern
wielding multiple rings now somebody to
point out here is this had not really
been touched on since the days of
emerald foiling that was really the last
time we'd seen anything like that when
Hal Jordan taking all the rings of the
former Green Lantern's that he defeated
you know and just kind of using those
rings for his own purposes
sort of supercharging his own Green
Lantern powers that was really the last
time we had seen that but it set the
stage for what Geoff Johns is doing now
because suddenly we're going to start
seeing Green Lantern's really more than
one Lantern ring we're going to
see people like kyle rayner who are the
embodiment of all the rings so we're
going to see like all these crazy
scenarios with all these different
characters now the other half of this is
the anti-monitor and really with the
anti-monitor Leafeon the inner sanctum
of the celestial court the antimatter is
of course going through and kind of
experimenting on the whole anion the
living embodiment of willpower sort of
you know trying to if you're torture it
or gain information or at the very least
see if it can be you know corrupted and
transformed into something else the
motivations I don't think are entirely
explained here but it's the anti-monitor
so we know that whatever it is he's
doing is bad it's just you know villain
stuff but in the middle of all this Hal
Jordan the other Green Lantern's yo
those who are left they all basically
sort of race into the scene they end up
you know grabbing the embodiment of
willpower and racing off because at this
moment in time the perspective of the
Green Lantern's is that if the
embodiment of willpower is destroyed
willpower will go with it now we know
that's not the case but at the time they
don't know that at the time all they
know is that if the embodiment of
willpower is gone then they'll be nobody
to resurrect the Green Lantern Corps and
that's the reason why that's so
important because would Kyle Rayner he
was ion he was the host for willpower
and so when he was replaced as the host
for parallax what that meant was that
the ion whale was just kind of floating
out there in no-man's land somewhere but
if the ion whales destroyed there'll be
nobody to resurrect the Green Lantern
core they'll all be killed off and
that'll be the end of that and so really
one of the most important things to do
is to grab the host to grab the whale
and get out of there as fast as possible
and that's what they do you know they
all basically kind of grab these things
just race off but in these last few
moments what the Guardians do is they
emerge from the central power battery
from their own you know a little haven
in there so to speak and they basically
say we've rewritten the Book of Allah
and we now have new laws chief among
them is the idea that the Green Lantern
rings are now capable of lethal force
the Green Lantern's are now able to kill
and that's huge because the Green
Lantern's can't believe it it's kinda
like wow but what choice do the
guardians of the universe have when you
regarding into the universe you look out
you see that Sinestro yo Thal Sinestro's
formed his own Sinestro corazon Lantern
Corps and he's just laying waste to
every single Green Lantern that he comes
across what choice do you have the
guardians of the universe sit down and
say we don't have a choice if we're
going to defeat the Sinestro Corps we
have to
fire with fire and so from this point
going forward the Green Lantern rings
have now had the whole hold on lethal
force that's been removed the Green
Lantern's are now allowed to kill
members of the Sinestro Corps what
happens said guys if you are new here to
come and explain it make sure you guys
took the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video
make sure you drop a like some district
or war goddess stories so good and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]